mal wieder haben wir grüne und rote
Kräfte die an der Mehrheit vorbei
entscheiden jetzt wäre es Zeit für
Franziska Giffey einzusehen sie muss
gehen und das gleiche gilt für Bettina
Jahrgang die Verlierer die so tun als
seien sie die Gewinner die eine
regierungsanspruch aus einer klaren
Klatsche ableiten Berlin hat neu gewählt
denn die erste Wahl war nichts also
musste sie wiederholt werden die CDU hat
gewonnen und die bisher regierende
Koalition aus SPD Grünen und Linkspartei
wurde abgestraft trotzdem sieht alles
danach aus als ob sie weiter regieren
mal wieder haben wir grüne und rote
Kräfte die an der Mehrheit vorbei
entscheiden was genau bei der Wahl
passiert ist das wollen wir uns jetzt
einmal im Detail ansehen sie sind die
klaren Gewinner der Berlinwahl Kai
Wegner und die CDU die Union kommt eine
Neuwahl des Berliner Abgeordnetenhauses
auf 28,2% der Stimmen mit deutlichem
Vorsprung vor SPD und Grüne die beiden
in Berlin amtierenden Regierungsparteien
kommen jeweils auf nur 18,4 Prozent der
große Verlierer der Wahl die SPD mit der
amtierenden Bürgermeisterin Franziska
Giffey nicht nur bei ihrem Gang zu Urne
war die Wahl für die SPD-Politikerin
buchstäblich für die Tonne Franziska
Giffey sie weigerte sich ihren
Stimmzettel in eine zur Wahlurne
umfunktionierte Abfalltonne zu werfen
-3% Punkte im Vergleich zu ersten Mal
2021 für Giffey und die SPD ein Debakel
doch anstatt ihre Niederlage
einzugestehen möchte gfay dass das Rote
Rathaus in Berlin auch weiterhin unter
roter Regentschaft bleibt dass die CDU
mit ihrem Kandidat Kai Wegner fast 10%
Punkte mehr geholt hat ist Giffey und
ihrer Partei vollkommen egal ebenfalls
vom schlechten Wahlergebnis
unbeeindruckt ist grünen
Spitzenkandidatin Bettina jarasch mit
ebenfalls mickrigen
18,4%, möchte sie neue Bürgermeisterin
von Berlin werden Niederlage eingestehen
Fehlanzeige der Kampf um den
Bürgermeister Posten von Berlin er ist
eröffnet ein fulminanter Erfolg für die
CDU die die bisher regiert haben
dirigierende Bürgermeisterin Franziska
Giffey Bettina jarasch die Frontfrau der
Grünen und Klaus Lederer von den Linken
wurden abgewählt schön und gut so
funktioniert Demokratie haben sie nicht
aber auch einen störgefühl dabei wenn
Sie sich anschauen wie diese abgewählten
darauf reagiert haben dass sie abgewählt
wurden nämlich damit dass Franziska
Giffey zum Beispiel gesagt hat ja für
Platz 1 hat leider nicht gereicht sie
hofft noch auf Platz zwei als wäre Platz
1 in Reichweite gewesen ein sehr als
wäre es ein Kopf an Kopf Rennen gewesen
das war natürlich nicht der Fall sie
wurde abgestraft sie wurde abgewählt die
Berliner haben ganz klar gemacht dass
sie sich eine Veränderung in ihrer
Regierung wünschen und was mich stört
ich weiß nicht wie sie das Empfinden
aber was mich wahnsinnig macht ist die
Art und Weise wie grün und rot jetzt zu
tun als sei das nicht passiert beide
Frauen an der Spitze der Grünen und der
SPD haben gesagt sie würden eigentlich
gerne weiter regieren am wissen selber
im Roten Rathaus am liebsten selber als
Bürgermeisterin als sei nichts passiert
sie ignorieren völlig die Mehrheit ich
habe das Gefühl nicht nur hier in Berlin
aber gerade jetzt hier in Berlin wird an
der Mehrheit vorbei entschieden fragen
wir uns doch mal warum hat Berlin so
entschieden wie es entschieden hat
welche Probleme hatten die Menschen die
zur Wahl gegangen sind im Herzen als sie
ihr Kreuzchen gemacht haben war es das
Weltklima die Inflation auf der ganzen
Welt der Ukraine Krieg nein ich glaube
nicht ich glaube die Berliner sind weise
genug zu erkennen ja das sind echte
Probleme ja diese Dinge muss man ernst
nehmen aber hier in Berlin können wir
sie nicht lösen die Berliner wissen dass
sie Berliner Probleme in die Mitte
stellen müssen wenn sie in Berlin wählen
und genau das haben sie getan heißt
Migrationspolitik wir haben es an
Silvester gesehen es gab hier Gewalt für
übt mehrheitlich von jungen Männern mit
Migrationshintergrund machen wir uns
ehrlich so war es die Berliner waren
schockiert zu sehen was aus ihrer Stadt
geworden ist und das hat sie Umtrieben
als sie die amtierende Regierung
abgewählt haben diese Regierung die
jetzt so tut als wäre sie nicht
abgewählt worden das ist merkwürdig
genauso ist es mit Verkehrspolitik es
wird Politik gegen Autofahrer gemacht
aber die meisten Leute sind nun mal
Autofahrer Politik an der Mehrheit
vorbei und dann haben wir die
abgewählten die Verlierer die so tun als
seien sie die Gewinner die eine
regierungsanspruch aus einer klaren
Klatsche ableiten das kann nicht sein
und darüber sprechen wir mit dem
Demokratie Forscher Prof dr Werner
Patzelt missachten denn SPD und Grüne
mit ihrem regierungsanspruch jetzt die
Mehrheit
in einem parlamentarischen
Regierungssystem braucht nun einmal die
Regierung eine Mehrheit im Parlament
eine solche hat aber weiterhin die
bisherige Koalition
wenn es also bei SPD Grünen und Linken
den politischen Willen gibt ihre
Koalition vorzusetzen
dann nützt der Wahlsieg der Berliner CDU
überhaupt nichts in welcher zweckmühle
befindet sich die CDU im Moment wenn die
CDU sich jetzt durch ein Bündnis mit
grünen oder Sozialdemokraten doch noch
ins Rote Rathaus flüchten möchte dann
muss sie das durch demütiges kuscheln
vor den Forderungen des jeweiligen
Koalitionspartners erkaufen danke Herr
Professor Patzelt für das Gespräch wir
sehen es also es passiert immer wieder
es wird an der Mehrheit vorbei regiert
es wird an der Mehrheit vorbei
entschieden und natürlich ist es so das
wollen wir hier nicht in Abrede stellen
dass die Kräfte in einem Parlament die
eine parlamentarische Mehrheit
zusammenbringen auch regieren das ist
ganz klar was nicht beschäftigt und
vielleicht empfinden sie das ja auch als
einfach merkwürdig ist das hier ein
klarer besteht und das an dem vorbei
gesprochen wird das so getan wird als
gäbe es ihn gar nicht als sei hier
niemand abgewählt worden das ist
merkwürdig und es passiert doch immer
wieder es passiert doch immer wieder
machen wir uns doch mal ehrlich wer sind
wir denn als Land die meisten von uns
fahren nun mal Auto das ist wie es ist
trotzdem haben wir das Gefühl gerade
wenn wir uns die Grünen auf Bundesebene
anschauen dass eine Politik gegen das
Auto gemacht wird Autofahrer werden
verteufelt man hat das Gefühl man muss
ein schlechtes Gewissen haben nur wenn
man Auto fährt manche Leute sind eben
aufs Auto angewiesen für manche Leute
gehört das Autofahren zum Leben einfach
dazu so ist es und ich weiß nicht wie
sie empfinden aber ich werde mir das
Autofahren sicher nicht vermiesen lassen
von den Grünen das gleiche mit dem
Gendern 85% der Deutschen wollen nicht
Gendern also diese Kunstpausen machen
Lehrerinnen Bäcker innen oder backende
statt Bäcker sagen es ist eine
Kunstsprache die die meisten Menschen in
diesem Land ablehnen die Grünen und ein
Teil der Sozialdemokraten und linken
interessiert das nicht sie machen es
einfach trotzdem in den Ländern in denen
sie regieren in den Ämtern in den Unis
in den Schulen wird geändert zum Teil
kriegt man in den Klausuren in den Unis
und Schulen Punktabzug wenn man nicht
gendert gegen 85% der Mehrheit oder
Atomkraft wir kaufen Atomstrom von
unseren europäischen Nachbarn wir geben
dafür Geld aus und machen gleichzeitig
unsere eigenen Atomkraftwerke aus Robert
Habeck unseren Wirtschafts- und
Energieminister ist es egal er macht mit
dem sinnlosen Atomausstieg gegen den
Willen der Mehrheit weiter oder der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk die
Mehrheit der Deutschen will dass ARD und
ZDF zusammengelegt werden passiert aber
nicht denn im Moment haben wir eine
Regierung mit einem spd-bundeskanzler
und Grünen die wichtige Ministerien
belegen und es passiert genau gar nichts
obwohl die deutschen das wollen obwohl
die Mehrheit will wir sehen es wird beim
Gendern beim öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk bei der Atomkraft beim Auto
gegen die Mehrheit Politik gemacht das
ist genau was die Grünen tun und ein
Teil der Sozialdemokraten und Linken und
das ist nicht fair und was ergeben sich
daraus für Forderungen es ist doch
eigentlich ganz einfach die SPD soll
anerkennen dass die Koalition die sie in
Berlin geführt hat so nicht mehr
weitergehen kann das hier ein Wechsel
nötig wird Lars Klingbeil hat sie
erinnern sich als Olaf Scholz mit 1,6%
Vorsprung bei der Bundestagswahl 2021
gewonnen hat gesagt ja klar jetzt hat
die SPD den Regierungsauftrag und damit
hatte er Recht den hatte sie auch jetzt
liegt die SPD 10% hinter der CDU Lars
Klingbeil hat aber wieder gesagt
Franziska giffer wäre jetzt die Tat die
richtige die Berlin regieren soll ich
glaube nicht ich glaube er ist hier mit
zweierlei Maß jetzt wäre es Zeit für
Franziska Giffey einzusehen sie muss
gehen und das gleiche gilt für Bettina
ja ja jeder für sich repräsentieren sie
Minderheiten keine Mehrheiten mehr die
beiden sollten sich zurückziehen das
fällt anderen überlassen die die
Erneuerung bringen die jetzt in einer
demokratischen Koalition der Mitte nötig
ist denn dann ist richtig Schluss mit
Politik an der Mehrheit vorbei